[Musique]
les essentiels du Sénat
reconquérir notre souveraineté
économique
pénurie de masques de semi-conducteur
arrêt de certaines activités entre 2020
et 2022 la crise liée à la pandémie de
covid 19 et les tensions sur les
matières premières depuis l'éclatement
du conflit russe au ukrainien ont révélé
les faiblesses de l'économie française
selon les sénateurs Sophie prima Amel
gaker et Franck Montaugé la perte de
souveraineté économique de notre pays
s'accélère et frappe aujourd'hui
l'ensemble des secteurs
40% des intrants de l'industrie
française sont importés contre 29% il y
a 20 ans 80% des données des citoyens et
entreprises de l'Hexagone sont stockés
aux États-Unis
dans un rapport fait au nom de la
commission des affaires économiques les
sénateurs ont étudié thématiques par
thématique les dépendances et fragilités
qui menacent l’économie française
sur cette base il propose 5 plans de
mesure structurantes pour commencer dès
demain à reconquérir notre souveraineté
le premier plan vise à garantir
l'approvisionnement de l'économie la
hausse des importations nourrit le
déficit commercial et nous rend captifs
d'acteurs étrangers aux intérêts plus ou
moins alignés avec les nôtres
la priorité est de réduire la dépendance
aux intrans importés en combinence stock
stratégique relocalisation et
diversification par exemple en matière
de métaux critique ou de denrées
alimentaires de base le deuxième plan
concerne les infrastructures
énergétiques et numériques vieillissante
et sous dimensionnée les sénateurs
suggèrent d'accélérer les
investissements dans le nucléaire et le
stockage d'énergie il souhaite déployer
un réseau indépendant de câbles
sous-marins reliant la France aux
différents pays de l'UE et localiser nos
données sur le territoire européen le
troisième plan d'action vise à assurer
la souveraineté dans les métiers et les
compétences de demain par un
investissement durable dans
l'apprentissage et la formation continue
en particulier dans le Cloud ou
l'électronique
le quatrième plan appelle à rééquilibrer
la politique commerciale de la France et
de l'UE en renforçant le contrôle des
produits importés ainsi que l'évaluation
des accords de libre-échange les
rapporteurs demandent aussi à adapter le
mécanisme d'ajustement carbone aux
frontières de l'Europe afin de combiner
compétitivité industrielle et ambition
environnementale enfin le cinquième plan
porte à plus fines échelle sur les
entreprises les trois sénateurs
insistent sur l'importance de protéger
notre tissu productif et d'affirmer son
ancrage territorial il souhaite par
exemple rééquilibrer le contrôle des
concentrations pour mieux lutter contre
les acquisitions prédatrices et
favoriser la constitution de filières
stratégiques européennes
pour en savoir plus consultez la
synthèse du rapport
[Musique]